I'm a carnivore I'll have like a big
piece of meat with a side plate of meat
and then maybe a couple shreds of
lettuce that's a good burger nice tomato
are you ready yeah okay do it but it
doesn't have that crispy outer edge so
it just seems like it's medium without
all of the like promise that's really
good great sauce really strong sauce
very salty maybe look too salty it does
like this salt masks the meat flavor
this feels like like a backyard burger
made by someone who doesn't really cook
that much yes this to me rings of like
it's inspired by a hamburger like based
on the true story of a hamburger but
it's not actually
oh so fiber is so different you know
yeah
also that pink this is coming off now
what is this
I guess it's to make me feel like hurry
are you upset what I'm impressed
I mean that bad was I ate most of it
before I noticed
I'll still eat it I meant to it I
thought it was me like a stringy I did I
would say I did think was me I don't
know what's gonna happen you don't just
go to a burger tape that can get very
Grey's anymore in the u.s. an average
family of four emits less greenhouse
gases driving two cars compared the
amount of meat they consider really Wow
that's crazy
when I bite into a meaty juicy steak I
honestly never thought about the
greenhouse damage the gases I admitted
fast-food burger chains serve that in a
restaurant and it was more readily
available I would eat it yes there you
go right now you can't go out you can't
walk down snap and just buy that yes oh
if the system changes out you know what
I'll think about it more it's good to
know this for right now if burgers are
my favorite food guys like burgers don't
make me feel bad about it I'm still sad
that I don't think I'm gonna be eating
some five formate burger